[Music]
they're gonna fight for another one
though and this one body's name stops
the queue here come bowel and as well to
be one proxxon may have been shooting
down guys in League of Legends mid
laners and a DC's seem to get all the
glory but we here at the score eSports
like to shine a light on those players
who live in the shadow of their fed
carries
I mean what's more anime than a heroic
underdog story
am I right Dimitri now guys we already
made a best of four league of legends
support players so now it's time for
junglers to get their due and you know
what that means plenty of smite plays of
the Baron and dragon variety lots of
ganks and yeah a few fails from junglers
who flashed too close to the Sun and
pray of course you know again the first
player to have a truly massive game on
Kalista you played it well already
getting close oh wow up there he's
actually in between the Sentinels he
missed the visions they didn't see him
Bank wow that is awesome that is sneaky
nunu right there bad the Sentinels
coming in he goes for the red seal
immediately he has smite he's going to
get it so looks like or do they be
getting red buff gap he's got kiss my
cam shows a bit and you know what he's
not even gonna be seen no just come on
get behind it I was just gonna eat it on
his way out
bengi could just be because you got a
good early start they're going with it
but it's definitely definitely impact
coming out with John and then
the Wallabies Saiga don't quite line
native diamond going to speed away when
insect comes in behind génifique Susan
Ward's back kicks in that is so hard to
execute even though Europe tried to come
when it made really everyone sit on the
rumble ultimate they'd already lost her
ad carry and they burned all their CC
release encountered Russia Asia so the
rest of Korea just chase down here so
many games where it's like I'll play the
pure I got seven kills on her and then
she goes yeah well speed of kills though
was insane it Bonnie's gonna roam and
gank towards burrow hole into the cocoon
the follow-up and Koro welcome back to
the LPL have a first one it's now
completely back to square one kuroh
ethically fine now he's been gifted wave
off the wave by five seven hasn't had an
impact
oh but Koro seems like he's gonna be
picked off flash that is gonna be
possible the flame holds him back in and
Koro has got to have his head in his
hands right now they're going to try
diving this and they will be able to
pick up the kill but that was just
brutal they didn't even get the spin
that go to Monica I'm gonna have to be
the real hero it's been good has he been
amazing he might be able to feel like
Smith the execute Mike Yaga look at the
steel the way the Bourbon is getting
chunked he has to be carefully to buy
time because this is gonna choke that
he's gonna kill all
the kalmyk you're the Thank You bear and
empowered speed does get them get there
a little bit quicker and this might be
the last push onto this inhibitor turret
that's fire 40:1 city kids back the
frontline they found Emma sentences
godlike young cannot do wrong this game
everyone else feels a bit scattered or
kind of a bit wait it's one side and you
can eat you toxic that was great wall
the hood went so far to get the insect
on the mystical shield they're able to
avoid him the long goes down in the back
in Connie's that are tried to
assassinate it but that is way too deep
stages ideas they keep him up so he goes
death and they're going to try to
collapse initiate he goes down but
that's Conde dropping as well along is
cutting it out on the back and Ben is
running for his life and this looks like
they dropped Connie with a big fourth
pulling print 9 5 7 gets a shadow - but
he's not long for this world
mara mana just popped through here a big
boosted damage for her guy coming into
this can they get her on the choppers
without hitting right just glory doesn't
really get in there says Hwanhee
ultimate if TSM can make it through this
they got it but cloud 9 is locking them
down lyrics and on the outside he gets
walked in with the position reverser how
is TS I'm still alive in this one they
are doing everything they can but cloud
9 closes the door on that fight and like
stay host now is gonna move it lands by
the prank it was not it's actually gonna
go in but that's the flash boss sparks
goes in once the big play you know wait
for at least to repel back down misses
that first queue but the snares in there
and rises more than enough damn and you
try to cut around those bottling
water save whoa that was gorgeous
he bought so much time with the
spiderlings blocking or trying to make
the spiderlings block there was a faint
move from sneaky down to the bottom lane
looking at the baby collapse of the goop
honestly doesn't want to walk the fog of
war
he's got the damage banker gets the
shutdown well play by us PT jungle this
started out how smoothy gonna run out of
unbreakable well he will be broken
picked up blank getting his third kill
the game an immaculate engage and this
is a difference between the two teams
say didn't know where the lease in is so
they don't go for the play now maybe on
to Lupo which was in trouble cocoon by
he kept off the /female stuff there's so
much damage they're still gonna force
they're just going straight forth they
think dignitas out of position their
rights car is killing the dragon right
now he needs to get off of that he does
take it down that's a bit of goal here
it comes to teleport and it's [ __ ]
Cruiser have it know that it's not gonna
happen for you frogs they get in it's
gonna be getting out of the fight that's
gonna be tough it's crews are right in
the back line crunch tries to I think I
can I think I can help you and he may be
able to on to boy boy but the focus is
they're cursed you can almost hear the
calm
you know something about spikes Neels it
would be safe [ __ ] but he did not
give our zombie a chance to miss that
one
Oh Devon fighting for Sarah big enough
to punch away to get done Jensen gonna
dive back in a snake he is able to grab
this knife they bought the cooldown for
a bit and now hazel wants to get away
he's put into the grinder buyback
we saved up with a Nazi I know you can
do that are they gonna fight for another
one though and this one body Sam stops
the queue here come fowl and as well to
v1 Proxima have been on for that he can
shooting down each maybe trying to set
up for Snoop a hair Snoopy's now coming
towards that mid lane and Phillips
coming around mid lane you can see
they're gonna dive on to a village goes
down this give me rice do those tanks it
up without putting Duke besides you just
turn the tables with Messiah backing it
up I do not believe me just walk off
so guys jungle pathing is cool I guess
but one of the hypest things a jungler
can do is a last minute death-defying
smite steel and let's be honest that's
really why we're here isn't it this is a
really good opportunity for them
weightless too long this parent is gonna
take too much time and deploy this have
to get it pretty much
lips over and steal said athena roll
tease them out to disengage the theme I
am hold on to this game
what more do you want from your uncle
but I don't think you make it in time
about flash and smite and Phoenix wants
to assassinate you just very damaged not
quite enough maybe if that is the type
of play that could tilt you unreal oh
boy the party portal looks like it's
coming in here and now the trap is
sprung
they're getting suppressed he's gone
down but mouse his Chi is gonna get
popped Vander a little bit too low in
this one is goodbye game
straik down to 7,000 will we actually
see a fall avoid looking for a massive
plank here on the other side they're all
the dragon look might get the seals on
maple
[Applause]
came back covered double sputtering
Pelican but this is
pareo in the final massive game changer
at the top he would have lived Andy's
here get it get it be stolen please stop
Baron and he got out
oh what a play that is pantheon please
sit guys the table they still have to
worry about XP smiling this they don't
have vision just yet all they is trying
to get some here bear and what quarter
HP berry berry man that [ __ ] be wanting
to go over the wall
oh my god and he gets out go to chasing
him but it's actually Team Liquid who
steal from the hundred days they will
have plenty of damage infernal and
fountain Drake all being amplified by
the elder dragon pop comes out great up
flashes over the ass Cheryl comes up
with a steal proto ship will keep it
alive for now but can he make it out of
the pit quick draws over popped up by
the depth charge he should go down at it
but peanuts that hero play guys let that
last section be a lesson to you and your
pub games when you try to go for baron
or a dragon now speaking of pub games
even the best junglers in the world can
make mistakes worthy of solo queue here
are the best or I guess worst jungler
fails then like a coat deal if this
thing gets really gonna move back down
towards the Wolves will stop peanut now
Curie's gonna hit it damn it is never
the rebuffs helping sense care gets a
bit of a hill then outfit you get a
dragon ready down first here and the
start thought about that but but buffet
car spends also in as well to be - it's
perfectly there for counter girl
breaking out fake it doesn't Lee get
somebody's chasing Pearson backspin now
gonna get caught in a flash flood yeah
go straight towards and slow gonna hit
she was gonna move in as well he hops
out of the way but peanuts still tagged
him does commit to the queue at the end
and that's been gonna try and turn it
back around in isolation but yeah he's
not coming Fred's got no help oh that's
another kill
the patients from peanut is just so so
beautiful when I played against TSM it
was really easy playing expense Karen so
that's why I left TSM out and you see
blank on your screen he's got three
marks already spawn so a little bit more
Oh small dogs around that's all right
thing
Oh times 2 I really hope you can there
we go yeah all right we got there in the
end it's okay
no one's all ready everybody let
spectators a jerk playing don't you
listen to him I think your class World
Championship SKT a much-deserved big
crabs at Blanc getting startled by the
confetti cannons absence car cake set in
one of the solo lanes and eat as I
should take in diana hart this to do it
camera was on you for that one saying
look at his face though you see that
camera you didn't flinch even a1 b1 you
can get an easy solo kill at 6 if you
can knock that passive off to set it up
now mouse' hardt is a team based
champion as we keep siding and cloud 9
keep picking it you know for their team
play it roaming around with credit or
fine pics busy though I'm a hard time
finding the ward this time around 0-3
against the control word there that has
pages their performance misty loses
fights that hard all according to plan
on the way back Wow
the sickest outplay I have seen this
summer split the first at five and now
we have three and eight minutes and
thirty seconds so at least all the
minutes since five they've really been
picking up kills for themselves
oh I do I'm gonna go ahead and say that
wasn't on TSN the website you know at
level seven you should probably died the
holes back to your base now spent
schedule is gonna make its own move
topside level six are both top and it's
rigged up the jungler in it as well a
lot of damage coming in towards liveries
gonna also stay alive but now Finn is on
the chase but Bo's burn the flat but is
to the knock up the top floor all's come
through but watch what the spirit is
attacking and spend scarin kills himself
in the top lane and fnatic is not done
jumping forward his camps he's got the
chain as well they don't lose too much
for that though they do lose that top
wave that top wave is going to go
straight into that turret how they hatch
look here lose the experience on
multiple members and crumbs oh my god
if crumbs dies here
oh my god oh my god wait a minute all
right let's reset reset take a breath
well guys that's it for the best jungler
plays in League of Legends now if you
don't want more content like this smite
the subscribe button gank a like button
and do comment below what anime you want
Dmitry watching next and remember it's
got to be safe for work see you next
time
am I right Dmitry in the background like
that a dog was like everything a Bears
head off or a bigger a bigger dog or
something I read